Florence's approach has many coastal
cities and towns in the southeast
worried about the potential for
devastating flooding and other damage
David beg no is in one of those coastal
towns Wrightsville Beach North Carolina
where people already are on alert David
good morning Nora good morning the
sunrise is beautiful already see some
surfers out in the water the waters
pretty quiet this morning you wouldn't
know we are standing in what could be
the bullseye where hurricane Florence
makes landfall in the southeastern US
and look if Florence hits here as a
category 4 it would be the strongest
storm to ever make landfall north of
South Carolina people in Wilmington
North Carolina are already stocking up
on water plywood and generators
preparing for the storm store shelves
are already empty Florence could be the
first major hurricane to slam North
Carolina dead-on since Fran hit as a
category three in 1996
Fran toppled homes and businesses across
the state it caused more than eight
billion dollars in damage and 37 people
were killed
these storms are catastrophic events
Andrew wonderly works for a water
conservation group in South Carolina
he says the low-lying cities on the
coast are particularly vulnerable to
flooding I think what we found is that
we're not really that prepared for these
events in October of 2015
a storm system caused 36 dams to fail
across the state of South Carolina
resulting in what was called the
thousand-year flood we saw it for
ourselves the Columbia Canal has
breached threatening the water supply to
more than 350,000 people at least 25
people died if Florence ends up stalling
after it makes landfall in the
southeastern US the fear is that could
happen again just get prepared prepare
for the worst but hopefully
look if you love to surf and you're
hoping that the swells from Florence
will give you a wild ride be careful
yesterday off the Central Coast of
Florida a man drowned while surfing all
right here's the deal the time to
prepare as you heard that official state
is right now Virginia says they could
issue evacuations today every state
North Carolina South Carolina Virginia
has their Emergency Operations Center
operational look right now we don't mean
to alarm you but now is the time to go
shopping get your plan ready and prepare
for this hurricane back to you now is
the time thank you David